impulsivo y trabajador así es descrito
eduardo país elegido alcalde del río de
janeiro que ya estuvo en el cargo entre
2009 y 2017 y es recordado por impulsar
a la ciudad como sede de los olímpicos
de 2016 vivan los juegos olímpicos y
bienvenida a la llama olímpica en la más
bella e increíble de todas las ciudades
el amor de mi vida río de janeiro muchas
gracias
ya no por el partido centroderechista
demócratas y venció al pastor evangélico
marcelo crivella que contaba con el aval
de la ultraderecha brasileña y esperaba
ser reelegido sin embargo páez es un
personaje polémico que ha sido
investigado en varias ocasiones por
corrupción y tiene procesos abiertos
está imputado por corrupción pasiva y
lavado de dinero por supuestamente
recibir donaciones ilegales para sus
campañas electorales de la constructora
odebrecht y es investigado por
licitaciones públicas para obras que
ríos son los juegos olímpicos de 2016
por su parte en la ciudad de sao paulo
fue reelegido el alcalde bruno cobas
también de centroderecha por el partido
de la socialdemocracia brasileña
la ciudad enfrenta graves problemas de
tráfico vivienda contaminación y
violencia
actualmente cobas lucha contra un tumor
en los ganglios linfáticos
la ciudad atraviesa un momento difícil
la pandemia ha requerido muchos
sacrificios de toda la población
como es un momento difícil y pongo mi
experiencia a su disposición y mis ganas
de trabajar aún más por la ciudad de sao
paulo para trabajar
aínda máis de la ciudad son las
elecciones del domingo realizadas en 57
ciudades son un significativo revés para
la ultraderecha del presidente ya ir
bolsonaro pero también para la
fragmentada izquierda de lula da silva
tanto en sao paulo como en río las
elecciones se produjeron con una
abstención récord y bajo estrictas
medidas de seguridad a causa del coi 19